tu avec david giraud porte-parole
jeunesse de la france insoumise et
jacques smith bonsoir déléguée nationale
de l'association étudiante uni bonsoir
messieurs merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur rt france je vais commencer
avec vous david giraud que pensez vous
de ce cafouillage en termes de
communication il n'y aura pas de prime
exceptionnelle finalement pour les
bénéficiaires de l'apl selon vous bah
écoutez c'est à se demander s'il ya un
pilote dans l'avion
moi je suis en colère parce que vous
savez ça fait longtemps que je dis que
le gouvernement d'ailleurs pas paix
solide emmanuel macron abandonne sa
jeunesse aujourd'hui dans le pays à un
jeune sur cinq 20% des jeunes de moins
de 30 ans qui sont pauvres
ça veut dire un jeune sur cinq sous le
seuil de pauvreté on avait déjà fait des
propositions la france heures soumises
avant le confinement dans le confinement
avant l'épidémie pour dire écoutez
prenez en compte cette réalité
aujourd'hui des jeunes sont gravement
touchés par le confinement et là on a un
effet d'annonce qui malheureusement
déçoit les jeunes et je pense que c'est
frustrant c'est rageant pour des jeunes
qui peinent à joindre les deux bouts qui
ont été durement touchés par les
politiques gouvernementales souvenez le
cap cana d'emmanuel map quand même
commencé avec cette histoire de de
suppression des appels et j'attire quand
même votre attention sur le fait qu' il
y a eu une référence des appels en 2021
et c'est pas cher qu'elles profitent aux
jeunes les jeunes actifs notamment
risquent de perdre une partie de leur
appel dès cette année ou l'année
prochaine donc tout ça est grave
moi je suis très honnêtement je suis en
colère et encore plus en colère que tout
à l'heure en séance en hémicycle ya des
députés de la france soumise comme eric
coquerel qui ont interpellé le
gouvernement pour demander des réponses
et on n'a toujours pas de réponse ces
gens là vivent dans une tour d'ivoire il
ne répond pas aux questions devant la
représentation nationale y est je ne
sais pas ce qui se passe au sommet on a
vraiment l'impression qu'il ya plus de
pilote c'est votre avis également
jacques à smith et il n'y a plus de
pilote dans l'avion si je puis dire
avec ce cafouillage en tout cas en terme
de communication là on est d'accord
c'est effectivement que tous les
étudiants et les jeunes et surtout les
étudiants sand en plein flou aujourd'hui
or de l'université n'arrive plus à gérer
tout ce qui est de voir de voir maison
cours à distance présentiel et donc
effectivement il ya des annonces qui
arrive très tard par exemple dimanche
soir et que le lundi les étudiants se
disent ah oui effectivement j'ai courant
distant ciel au lieu du présentiel
donc il y a un gros flou donc
effectivement on se demande que allah
quoi sert le gouvernement et surtout sur
l'enseignement supérieur à quoi sert le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
puisqu'aujourd'hui il devrait être
effectivement ce garde-fou en tant
qu'art l'instant c'est le ministère qui
donne en tout cas une à cap pour pour
toutes les universités aujourd'hui les
universités sont laissés complètement
pour compte ils sont seuls face à la
crise sanitaire
seuls pour gérer ces milliers
d'étudiants de l'enseignement supérieur
français alors qu'il faudrait penser à
parce que les étudiants pourquoi pour
avoir un boulot notamment après on va
sûrement en parler la première précarité
de la jeunesse c'est surtout ne pas
avoir de boulot après ses études à voir
un premier job est aujourd'hui arrivée
sur le marché du travail
on le sait très bien c'est compliqué
pour les nouveaux n 2 pour les tout
nouveaux et 3 après une licence un
bachelor ou un master c'est devenu très
compliqué de rentrer sur ce marché du
travail et donc le ministère là aurait
un immense pouvoir de deux guides et
deux aides aux établissements pour
pouvoir insérer ces jeunes donc vous
vous demandez plus de clarté en termes
de communication pour ce qui est des
mesures en général dans les universités
revenons-en aux primes exceptionnelles
david guiraud l' on explique bien que
ces primes sont accordés parce que
justement beaucoup d'étudiants de
travail et dans la restauration ou dans
les bars oui mais moi je crache pas sur
les aides
on a besoin que l'état intervienne en ce
moment c'est parce que c'est la
solidarité qui doit primer mais regardez
une chose simple la france insoumise
pendant la campagne par exemple de 2017
est d'ailleurs bien avant et ce n'était
pas la seule organisation
il ya beaucoup de gens dans ce pays qui
vous disent écoutez ouvrait le rsa aux
18-25
c'est une revendication ancienne de dire
ouvrait le rsa aux 18-25 a pas de raison
de ne pas l'ouvrir à des gens qui
commencent d'ailleurs déjà travaillé
souvent à 18 ans elle pour certains même
à 16 ans aux ouvres et le augmenter le
rsa si on avez
le rsa aux 18-25 d'ailleurs je me suis
un peu le gouvernement moi j'ai eu des
gens de la majorité en marche qui m'ont
dit qu'ils étaient en train d'y
réfléchir pendant le confinement temps
dans les débats télé ils m'ont dit ça je
ne vois toujours pas le rsa être ouvert
aux 18-25
et cette aide là qui a été fait
aujourd'hui enfin en tout cas qui a été
annoncé hier par eau par emmanuel macron
elle concerne les dix les gens qui sont
éligibles au rsa
si on avait ouvert le rsa aux 18-25 il
n'y aurait pas eu ce problème de
cafouillage ou de kouakou de cacophonie
ça aurait rendu les choses plus simples
mais aujourd'hui je le dis il n'y a pas
que cette aide qui est importante il ya
des étudiants aujourd'hui qui sont très
durement impactée moi je pense et c'est
une proposition qu'on avait fait pendant
le confinement et qu'on va et réitérée
justement pendant le couvre feu parce
que vous l'avez dit il ya des gens qui
vont être en galère pour payer leur
logement c'est de suspendre
temporairement les loyers étudiants
pendant cependant cette crise là c'est
possible pour notamment c'est facile
pour les jeunes en crous parce que le
crous c'est notamment l'état et pour les
jeunes qui sont dans des loyers privés
on rembourse les bailleurs privés parce
que tout le monde n'est pas un loueur
milliardaire donc ça c'est des
propositions concrètes
après vous on parle par exemple de
d'allocations d'autonomie pour dans les
études faire en sorte que les étudiants
n'est plus à travailler ça je veux bien
qu'on ait un débat là-dessus ça va plus
loin que ces propositions là mais par
contre le rsa aux 18-25 augmenter le rsa
suspendre les loyers étudiants
c'est une urgence pendant l'année
dernière on tourne en début d'année il y
avait déjà un jeune sur cinq en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté
aujourd'hui ça va être extrêmement
compliqué et il ne faut pas sacrifier
les jeunes n'ont pas à subir ça
notamment parce qu'on va avoir besoin
d'eux on va voir avoir besoin d'une
jeunesse qualifiée d' une jeunesse bien
formée et c'est pas possible dans ce
contexte là où on est en train de subir
la précarité et la misère sociale ouvrir
le rsa aux 18-25 ans est votre avis
également jacques snif on sait que les
apl finalement sont accordé à as ton
d'un sans condition de ressources
notamment des parents est ce qu'il
faudrait revoir ce dispositif selon vous
non le maintien le maintien des appels
pour tous et une est une bonne chose et
nous à l'union l'a toujours on l'a
toujours défendu tout simplement parce
que on a toujours défendu une mesure qui
défend des tous les étudiants et qui a
impacté tous les étudiants
malheureusement souvent les nouvelles
mesures d du ministère souvent ne
touchent qu'une partie malheureusement
donc les appels font partie de ces aides
qui touche effectivement les étudiants
dans leur ensemble
à prime exceptionnelle serait accordé
aussi hauts revenus qui n'en auraient
pas forcément besoin des revenus aisés
ce qu'il faut est tout à fait dans ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que plus de
toute façon le début du confinement
aujourd'hui il y avait deux idéologies
ou deux camps qui skie ce qui ce qui se
confrontent entre effectivement toujours
plus de dépenses publiques toujours plus
de deux d'argent en verre effectivement
l'enseignement supérieur et donc oui il
faut il faut de l'argent plus tard mais
déjà premièrement on peut le trouver
dans des endroits où parfois il y à des
fraudes ou parfois il peut y avoir aussi
des aides qui ne sont pas touchées par
les étudiants et puis en face de ce camp
là de la dépendent toujours plus de
dépenses publiques sur des êtres qui
parfois ne sont pas utilisés il y a
aussi le camp de trouver où est l'argent
et surtout des des mesures pragmatiques
qui touche l'ensemble des étudiants non
voilà depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire sur trois choses très
concrètement la première sur la
restauration typiquement il ya eu une
annonce de de deux depuis le début de
cette année en sept ans sur le 1 1 euro
le ticket resto à 1 euro pour les
boursiers c'est une ça ça va dans le bon
sens juste que les non boursiers ne
touche pas c'est cette aide
or les non boursiers sont souvent issus
des classes moyennes notamment où c'est
là les familles qui aide les étudiants
et les familles ne sont pas son dos si
durement attaqué par cette crise
sanitaire donc ils ne peuvent pas
toujours aidé la leur leurs étudiants
donc là dessus on demande nous une autre
mesure de restriction qui est le ticket
est une langue qui toucherait l'ensemble
des étudiants deuxièmement le logement
le logement on a parlé des bailleurs et
on a parlé de des apn ce qu'il faudrait
tout simplement c'est notamment exonéré
les charges pour pourquoi effectivement
les privés qui louent à des kills ou à
des étudiants alors pas du tout tout
enlever mais en tout cas alléger et puis
sur l'insertion professionnelle parce
que quand vous êtes jeune et encore une
fois la première précarité c'est de ne
pas avoir de boulot
donc quand vous êtes jeunes et étudiants
le but c'est d'être de s'insérer sur le
marché du travail
et bien c'est aussi hélas on avait
défendu un amendement d'un député john
députés de droite pendant confinement là
dessus c'était d'exonérer les les
charges fiscales et patronales à
l'embuscade jeunes de moins de 30 ans il
cependant
cependant deux ans - david guiraud on a
entendu le
de l'état mercredi dire que être jeune
aujourd'hui en temps de crise c'était
pas simple or les mots sont là mais les
gestes vraisemblablement ne suivent pas
les jeunes sont les éternels oubliés et
particulièrement en cette crise
sanitaire
bah écoutez être jeune en 2020 c'est dur
d'être pris pour des imbéciles c'est
pire parce que là c'est ce qui se passe
je veux dire au bout d'un moment on va
pas on peut pas non plus se cacher
derrière son petit doigt en permanence
on annonce une aide qui finalement
n'aura pas lieu
c'est pas normal c'est un manque de
respect et vous savez la parole du
président elle fait foi dans les
discours présidentiels bratton que c'est
censé être mise en acte après donc moi
je écoutez moi je pense qu'il ya pas 36
manières de voir les choses
les étudiants comme un temps au
printemps et les actes avaient été avait
été suivie des des paroles ou pas mais
le problème c'est que sur les jeunes en
fait le problème qu'on a sur les
étudiants c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas
comprendre ni nous ils nous disent par
exemple on va faire des aides pour que
bon moi je suis con par exemple le
dispositif d'exonérations fiscales aux
entreprises pour les premiers emplois
parce que ce qu'est ce qui va se passer
on va les recruteurs stage on va les
recrutés en cdd et derrière il y aura
pas de recrutement massif c'est ça qui
va se passer
moi je pense qu'on a besoin déjà de se
dégager d'une certaine vision qui est
que le jeune doit absolument trouver son
boulot direct après des études menant
d'abord le jeune doit bien être fort
mais il faut commencer par là faut
prendre les choses dans l'ordre
bien sûr qu'après il faut trouver un
travail mais il doit bien être formés il
doit être utile à la société on est en
étant le mieux formés possible
et pour être bien formé moi je suis
désolé mais ça peut pas se faire en
travaillant à mi-temps et on sait que le
travail par exemple au bout de seize
heures par semaine ça diminue
mécaniquement les chances de réussite
enfin en tout cas la réussite au pendant
les études
donc prenons les choses dans l'ordre une
allocation d'autonomie pour permettre de
d'arrêter d'avoir à travailler à des
petits boulots ça c'est une première
chose pendant la crise il ya des choses
concrètes à faire suspendre les loyers
ouvrir le rsa aux 18-25
ce qui permettrait de donner cette aide
exceptionnelle d'ailleurs aurait aux
18-25
ça ce sont des choses semblent augmenter
le rsa à long terme peut-être que c'est
pâques en augmenter le rsa long terme
voilà moi je pense qu'il faut voir les
choses dans l'ordre
parce que si vous voulez à chaque fois
le ce gouvernement il fait toujours la
même chose il nous dit écoutez c'est un
peu le chantage au bordel en jeu
le dit comme ça c'est que en gros on est
dépassé par la situation
du coup on fait un peu n'importe quoi
mais bon on n'a pas le choix vous prenez
parce que la situation est grave
oui la situation est grave et par
exemple nous ça fait un mois et demi
qu'on dit que la politique de tête ça ne
marche pas ça fait des années que je me
bats pour dire que dans les universités
il ya trop de monde il ya beaucoup trop
de monde qui sont entassés parce que les
universités manque de moyens et que du
coup les gens sont obligés de s'entasser
les uns sur les autres sur des amphis
qui sont pas rénovés
donc voila moi il ya un moment où il
faut porter un projet de société d'une
société à taille humaine dans les
logements pour les jeunes parce que
c'est pas normal aujourd'hui pour un
jeune de s'entasser sur les bancs des
amphis et deux derrière foncé pour aller
travailler au mcdo ou faire hubert quand
on sait que ces 400 500 euros de revenus
par mois pour un travail difficile et
qui vous compliquer vos études voilà
prenons les choses dans l'ordre
faisons les choses bien et arrêtons de
prendre les jeunes pour des imbéciles
jacques smith c'est un tout tout ce dont
on vient de parler ce sont des problèmes
finalement qui existaient déjà et qui
sont exacerbées par cette crise oui tout
à fait et puis ça de fait c'est la
définition du christ c'est que s'il y a
déjà des problèmes problème avant ça
c'est que sa soeur avec avec la crise je
suis d'accord bien évidemment il faut
prendre les choses dans l'ordre et et
prendre la formation des étudiants
tout d'abord avant avant l'an 500 après
il faut il faut pas il faut jamais
oublier que cette formation vise vous
êtes à l'université pour avoir un
diplôme mais ce diplôme va vous servir
pour pour avoir un travail mais
effectivement ce diplôme il doit falloir
quelque chose notamment et c'est pour ça
que le gross écueils et c'est là où
c'est le ministère le gouvernement a
quelque chose à faire et ça c'est
l'unique eux qui le demandent depuis le
début de la crise de faire en sorte que
les diplômes est encore une valeur
puisque vous parliez de formation chers
collègues mais il n'y a pas de formation
si vous n'avez pas de diplôme qu'ils
soient valorisés et malheureusement
certaines associations dans beaucoup de
chaque demande quelquefois de
neutralisation du semestre des 10 pour
tous énorme
absolument pas qui n'est absolument pas
les énormes et attendait 100 d'ici là je
suis désolé hongrie n'en mettrait la
pression et à carrière a pas rien avec
un discours tous oui c'est sûr qu'il
passera à quelqu'un d'autre
donc il n'aura pas son travail plus rien
à lorient les rediffusions réponse david
j
il faut il faut faire un peu les
arbitres avec un des débats à distance
david giraud rue danse tu comprends
juste ya rien de pire mais absolument
rien de pire que de ne pas aider les
jeunes à valider leur semestre leurs
trimestres aujourd'hui c'est pas très
grave
je vous le dis honnêtement c'est pas
très grave si pendant deux mois le suivi
des cours est moins bon et que bon la
qualité est un peu moins bonne parce que
par contre la rupture dans une année
pour un jeune qui est sous le seuil de
pauvreté qui a du mal à s'en sortir
c'est quoi déjà c'est quoi derrière
c'est le décrochage et le décrochage on
sait où ça mène s'amène dans des voies
de garage s'amène dans des petits
boulots à répétition à répétition et à
répétition et ça ça n'est pas possible
ce n'est pas un projet de société donc
oui parfois il ya des moments vous faut
être un peu souple sur les diplômes moi
je l'assumé c'est pas baisser la valeur
des diplômes mais en ce moment il ya une
urgence
si on sort les jeunes si on sort des
jeunes faut faire très attention un
jeune sur cinq entre du seuil de
pauvreté et ça va être de pire en pire
vu la période ya un million de chômeurs
qui arrivent on va arriver à 10 millions
de personnes sous le seuil de pauvreté
on va arriver à 8 millions de demandeurs
d'aidé alimentaire c'est pas le moment
de sortir les jeunes de l'université je
voulais très honnêtement et très
fermement
ça n'est absolument pas le moment non il
faut soutenir les jeunes on aura des
moments
évidemment quand l'épidémie sera fini
pour reprendre des cours plus
sérieusement effectivement mais par
contre les sortir du système
universitaire les sortir des filières
d'apprentissage ça serait une erreur
catastrophique qui mettrait beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes en grande difficulté
et dans la misère je rappelle qu'il ya
eu des moments dans l'histoire
par exemple pendant les manifs de 68 à
plein d'endroits plan moment où les
cours ont été perturbés il ya eu dès
validation automatique de course ça n'a
pas baissé l'intelligence des gens ça
n'a pas baissé la qualité des formations
les français sont intelligents ils
savent se débrouiller
évidemment c'est pénalisant je ne le nie
pas mais il ya des priorités dans la vie
aujourd'hui la priorité c'est pas de
savoir si on va rattraper un ou deux
mois de cours mais plutôt de faire en
sorte qu'aucun jeune sont en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté très peu de temps
jacques smith le mot de la fin vous
pouvez répondre ce sera ce sera la
dernière intervention
oui non c'est fou de défendre comme ça
le désert puisque 68 c'est pour moi ce
n'est absolument pas effectivement à une
année de d'exemple et c'est fou de
prendre l'année 1968 comme exemple pour
pour l'enseignement supérieur français
donc ça c'est déjà la première chose
bien sûr que si vous n'avez pas de
diplôme qu'ils soient valorisés kinetics
si vous arrivez avec un diplôme qui ne
vaut rien l'employeur ne vous prendra
pas et vous n'arriverez pas à vous
insérer son marché du travail et je veux
bien que vous vous préférez avoir des
jeunes qui restent trois fois en l2 et
quatre fois et le 3 mai au bout d'un
moment il faut pas
il faudra donner papeete
ils savent se débrouiller vous savez les
gens sont intéressants il faut se
débrouiller
il ne s'est pas de moins en moins qui
vont les rendre des bilans merci
beaucoup ce sera le mot dire merci à
david guiraud et merci à vous jacques
smith d'avoir participé à ce débat en
direct sur rt france